hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my youtube viewers I guess
who wrote in and asked as always having
a great video I have a question for you
I'm 49 years old I grew up in the diner
in the comfort food business my family
sold our diner 1999 I'm passion well
comfort food roast gravies homemade
soups etc not always a healthiest kind
of food but it's what I know best I want
to get back into that business for
myself how can i add more value for my
customers everyone is into organic and
healthier foods these days any ideas so
thank you for the question my thought
for you and for any entrepreneurs you're
starting out number one rules you have
to do something that you're really
passionate about so if you're super
passionate about comfort foods then
that's the business that you got to get
into if you don't really know about
organic and healthy foods or you're not
really excited about it your business
isn't going to go anywhere you're not
going to be successful so you have to do
something that you're super excited boat
and you can pour your whole heart into
so think back to the diner 99 and look
at other diners are successful and think
about now how can you replicate that
success but do it in a more modern way
right and how can you add a lot of value
to your customers but still provide the
food that you really love there are
people who want to buy from you not
everybody is into organic the organic
market is growing growing quickly but
it's still only a tiny percentage of the
overall market so there's still a
percentage who want to buy and want to
buy from you so you gotta cater to those
guys right don't worry about the entire
market worry about your specific market
pour your heart into it think about
everything you really loved about your
diner and what you think then a new
diner which should look like for people
like you and build it again if you're
really passionate about it that I'll
show through in the quality of the food
and the quality experience and you're
not going to target everyone and that's
a
okay and you're more likely to have
success than to try to go after
everybody if you're really curious about
organic you can still have organic
options you can do organic gravy and
organic you know chicken or stews or
whatever it is that you're going to be
providing but again it's got to be
something that you're really excited
about if you don't care about organic
then you know don't go that way follow
exactly what you're excited about and
again pour your whole heart into it
you're really excited about it put as
much as you can into the experience and
people who are like you and want comfort
food will say this is the place to come
to this is the best place in town and
hopefully tell our friends about it so
hopefully that helps you know 49 years
old you're not too old to start and and
I would don't don't worry about not
going through with it I think a big
thing a lot of entrepreneurs is they
think about an idea and they think it
may not work out so they never take that
leap and regret it for the rest of their
lives and i'm not seeing to absolutely
work out a lot of businesses do fail but
i think you owe it to yourself to know
if this would work out or not and so you
don't live the rest of your life
regretting that you didn't take your
shot at what could have been successful
business this hopefully that helps if
you guys liked the video please give it
a thumbs up and makes me to do more of
these videos for you guys and if you
have a question about this video or a
different question about your business
please leave a comment below and i will
try to answer it for you so thank you
and you'll see you on the next episode
you
you